in Phoenix Arizona über 40 Grad Celsius
seit nunmehr 18 Tagen am schlimmsten ist
es für die die im Freien leben sie
Tränken Tücher in Wasser werden im
kühlen Nebel einer rollenden Klinik von
Ärzten beraten Kevin hender Schott hat
in seinen zwölf Jahren auf der Straße so
eine Hitze noch nie erlebt
ich bin auf dem heißen Asphalt
eingeschlafen und hatte dann
Verbrennungen dritten Grades an meiner
linken Seite da merkst du was los ist
Augenöffner in den Nachrichten jeden Tag
schon seit Wochen
mit den tief roten Karten dreistelligen
Fahrenheit Temperaturen bis zu fast 45
Grad Celsius das müsste eigentlich auch
Leugner des Klimawandels überzeugen es
brennt nicht nur in Amerika wie hier in
Kalifornien sondern rund um den Globus
in Spanien
und den Kroatien
fast täglich neue Hitze Rekorde gibt es
auch in China also ist auf einmal der
us-klima Beauftragte John Kerry hier
wieder willkommen im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel sogar der US-Geheimdienst
CIA warnt angesichts der Ereignisse mit
unmissverständlichen Worten
Klimawandel verschärft dramatisch fast
jeder andere globale Bedrohung in den
Feldern energiegesundheit Nahrung die
Gefahren des Klimawandels sind kein
Problem der Zukunft sondern ein Problem
jetzt
das Extremwetter fordert Todesopfer bei
Überschwemmungen hier in Pennsylvania
sterben am Sonntag fünf Menschen und im
Südwesten gibt es neue hitzewarnungen
für rund 100 Millionen Amerikaner